A powerful telescope
has captured unprecedented
and really beautiful images of the sun's
surface, revealing sunspots
and other features in new detail.
Also, Saturn's
iconic rings
may not be visible
from Earth in the future.
Data analysis of NASA's
13 year Cassini mission
is unveiling
new insight into how long
those rings have been around
and when potentially
they'll vanish from sight.
Let's bring in now
president of Explore
Mars Inc., Janet Ivey, to discuss
that and more. Let's talk first.
Good morning about the sun
and these amazing images.
We're seeing some dark spots here.
We're seeing what I'm learning
are some bridges.
What do we see
looks like possible?
No, it's amazing
because what the new
telescope has captured
are these beautiful dark sun spots.
And we are in a time of solar maximum.
The sun goes through
an 11 year solar cycle.
So solar minimum to solar maximum.
We're in solar maximum.
What these sunspots are revealing,
they're seeing this.
It's weird
because it's like plasma pushing upwards
and then cooler plasma pushing downwards.
It's just beautiful.
They kind of look like honeycomb
or flames coming out.
These are regions
that are huge magnetic regions
that solar flares can occur
and then that can cause a lot of problems
here on Earth when they happen.
But as just an image
and beauty, it's beautiful.
And what's really weird
is that, Victor,
some of those sunspots
are three city blocks long.
And then the one really big one
you might be looking at
is at least as big
as the entire planet of Earth,
because here's a little sun fact.
Everybody needs to know over
1 million suns could fit.
I mean, 1 million Earths
could fit inside the sun.
Amazing. Can't even fathom.
These images are really beautiful.
And we're both lovers of art.
And I love the color
yellow or chartreuse.
I have it in my living room.
I will have to just blow that up.
And just
because it looks like acrylic art
or pasta as as a like noodles.
Right. We're back on the
of
Beautiful.
Go ahead.
Oh, Saturn's rings are amazing.
And this is new information.
Remember,
Cassini crash dived
at the end of its mission
and what it was doing,
it would sort of dove
in between those rings.
And scientists
noticed this interesting phenomena
called ring reign.
And so there for a long time,
we thought maybe something crashed
into Saturn.
That material dispersed.
And then,
you know,
the gravitational pull of Saturn
pulled those rings
and they began to spin around it.
Now, there may be some other evidence
that maybe there was once a moon
and maybe
the gravitational instability
call caused that kind of debris field.
But remember,
a lot of Saturn's
what's in Saturn's
rings are things made of comets,
asteroids, ice, rock and dust.
But what they're seeing
is every time
those rings that never stop spinning
get hit with
something out there in our solar system,
it's sort of sheering off
some of that
some of that ice
rock and debris in there.
So scientists
theorize that billions of years from now
that they may disappear
So I hope they stick around
for a long, long time.
So we have a little time,
billions of years from now.
They won't disappear on Monday.
We've got
we're going to go a while longer. Okay.
So let's turn now
to NASA's Mars rover Perseverance.
Friends call in Percy.
We're getting some new video
looking inside the belly of a crater.
What are we seeing
so Belva Crater is
kind of like a crater in a crater.
Remember, perseverance
landed in a place called
Jezero Crater
and its main mission is looking for life.
But this vista really kind of
has some scientists puzzling,
like the way
that the rock is sort of scattered
and some of the mosaic
and the way the sand structures are
really suggest
that there was faster
flowing water through this region.
And as Danny Rocha and Ted Lasso says,
football is life.
Well, water means life.
So that is the quest of perseverance,
is that we're looking for those by
biosignatures.
We're looking for fossilized
life, microbial life.
But what you're seeing
is just really this amazing crater
within a crater
that we know
that flowing water
existed at one point in history.
More to come, I'm sure, as scientists
keep reviewing that.
All right,
Janet Ivy,
always good to have you
on a Sunday morning.
Thank you so much.
Always learn something new.
I didn't know Saturn.
The rings are made up of asteroids
and debris and stuff.
Yeah, and Super B is a million
Earths into the sun. Had no idea.
All right. Thank you, Janet.